yeah welcome to this video playing you
for against Superman 5 and this guy is
very high rated 25 this is really high
in five minute five-minute pool so put
the comic-con ok my player play that on
the part of here don't really know what
the theory well anyway so
Bishop is six this is some not very
common but Bishop g4 more normal or g6
as I recently recommended in a in a
repertoire video for icc hmm really
yeah why not night you for him
hmm yeah this is all but strange but
maybe it's uh it's quite okay how to
continue I wonder if I can should I
should do something and maybe just this
come on play it simple I don't let's not
spend too much time and this is probably
not great what he did here but if i
spend two minutes for it it doesn't help
yeah probably g6 now no he didn't do
that
the other way you played on you hear
hear he allowed our esox to be played
yeah okay cannot play passive moves must
I must give give up upon to UM to get
activity don't want to play play this
and then the passive fashion that it
doesn't help so what now Queen Queen see
to something doesn't doesn't really lead
to much probably
yeah this bishop on d5 is really a major
major annoyance okay let's try a very
direct way to attack here now g5 queen
age five at least he's got many pieces
on the on the queenside
yeah well at least threatening to read
half seven it's a it's easy easy to see
but how does he prevent how to see an
answer this just castles but this might
might involve from getting into some
trouble at sam bishop age seven King
night f seven moons maybe not not so
great but night h7 night eh 78 f 619
probably needs to sacrifice the exchange
but Knight f6 is a threat
now I have six Queen h6 some night f6
takes bishop f6 and then Queen h6 this
is what I'm trying to talk about not f6e
probably what you can afford all that
yeah no way no way absolutely near this
is not possible Knight f6 first so I'm
and now I can just take d3r lc3 right
yeah should be should be enough really
now it takes just rook takes and I'm
going over here to g3 even he can never
take him
I cannot even play Bishop c4 because of
the queen is saying so what's the the
quickest the quickest win he wants to
move the bishop
yeah probably this is this is easiest
contending Bishop g5 to h6 Bishop g5 now
I'm still threatening Bishop h6 Bishop
h6 Queen a try Bishop g7 checkmate and
this is hopefully convincing at least I
don't see anything like a defense here
may I can still take it turn yeah to
bring the rocker but what about Queen
edge form queen age for threatening
Bishop g5 this must be resins now I
don't see a move
and meet ya I this was probably probably
completely incorrect for white but it
got dangerous here yeah computer wants
to go g6 but this is not easy for human
allowing the sacrifice here yeah it's
here night before really is this shocked
me a computer wants to go Bishop takes
d4 this is actually what I expected with
an advantage for black but this is
simply not not working yeah plus five
plus five is quite quite good enough
greentech Step five is also checkmate
windex f5 rock edge free Bishop f8 media
cannot be prevented but ok this is this
is also made ok yeah this was fun at the
end probably an incorrect opening but
it's not all of all openings yeah this
is surprised me but it's may be it may
be ok yeah thanks for watching this
video